hey
welcome everyone to the fourth day of
this workshop
uh we have three very exciting talks
today on online
learning on optimal stopping and on
market design and uh it's my pleasure to
welcome our first speaker perry elky
from raikkonen aip tokyo and he's been
kind enough to
join us on a very odd hour
at his place so let's without further
ado
let's get started
okay well first uh thank you thank you
very much for
for the the invitation um i'm gonna say
that i was very excited by the uh
the uh the program of the of the
workshop and i'm
uh of course like uh it's it's a bit
late here so i'm not able to attend all
the talks live but
i i definitely i'm looking forward to
watching uh the videos
uh and sorry that i cannot attend live
uh but anyway so this talk
uh is about uh some uh
regret bonds for online variational
inference
it's based on the paper that was
published last year uh with my
former phd student madridin sheriff de
latif who is now a
postdoc in stats at oxford and
uh mt khan who's the the leader of the
approximate beijing
inference team at freaking aip and i
joined this team actually just
at the time where we were writing this
paper
and actually i will start by a quick
motivation actually
when i joined the team at that time mt
was working with
many of his
quarters on uh on the paper actually
where they
they try to to to scale bayesian methods
to be able to to to train deep neural
networks
um as well as the state of the art
using non-bayesian methods so of course
the
the point is that if you if you try to
to use a bayesian method you expect that
in addition to point estimate
you get an estimate of the uncertainty
of
uh of your prediction and uh this is
what is represented here by the picture
on the right so
on the top you have like an image and
you try to analyze mini pages of this
image
and understand what they contain if it
contains a car the road
and actually um they estimated
uh a posterior for such for for a neural
network
and then actually this posterior uh if
you sample from it
uh you get an idea of the uncertainty of
the prediction and actually the
the zones that are highlighted in the
picture below corresponds to
high uncertainty in the prediction so
the point is that of course
uh bayesian methods if you if you look
at
textbooks on monte carlo method you have
very nice sampling algorithm but these
algorithms
are like difficult to scale
in reasonably high dimensions so for
unreasonably
unreasonably large dimension like the
kind of deep neural networks
considered in this paper it's absolutely
not feasible and
um it's not possible to target the exact
posterior so people
target approximations of the posterior
and the question is actually can we
understand these approximations and is
it possible to
to provide guarantees on the qualities
of these approximations
and i i would say so it's a big question
in some sense because they
are variational they are approximations
of posteriors
in many different frameworks and i
should say a word first
maybe about what kind of approximations
are used before i
i actually come to the online setting
so i remind just like a few notations in
beijing statistics
and based on machine learning so you
have a prior pi and
given a set of predictors that f theta
that you would apply on object x
and true levels y a loss function l
actually you can
propose a pseudo posterior of the form x
of minus eta times the sum
of uh the uh the loss functions
times the prior actually this is not
strictly sensu
bayesian inference this is why i call
that generalized bayesian inference
well when the loss function is a log
likelihood then eta is equal to one
this is actually beijing inference but i
will allow
like things to be a bit more a bit more
general
okay and as i said so this posterior is
not something that you can hope to reach
in many many problems because it's um
like it might be a very complicated
object
and the point is that this um this
posterior
it's been known actually for a very long
time that it can be rewritten
as a minimization problem uh it can be
rewritten as the minimize
the argument of the expectation
with respect to p off the lot of the sum
of the losses
plus the pullback divergence between p
and the prior so if you minimize this
with respect to p
over all the possible probability
distribution you will end up
with the posterior distribution
and um well this is a very difficult
meaning
if you just consider this as a
minimization problem it's over um
infinite dimensional space but
the point is this motivated actually the
introduction of
the kind of approximation that i will
study in this talk that are called
variational approximations
and the idea was well if this posterior
is too complicated
then let's replace it by the minimizer
of the same quantity
but on a smaller family and then
actually you say well
for example the family would be a set of
gaussian distributions
and then it makes things much easier
because instead of approximating
on a infinity dimensional set you will
simply
uh minimize with respect to a
finite dimensional set of parameters
okay so it appears that
there is a well-known theory that i
summarized very briefly
but very well known theory to study the
consistency of beijing inference so if
those
the true beijing posterior converges to
a kind of
direct mass that's the best possible
parameter
and it appears that um well
actually there is there are many
assumptions but one of the key
assumptions
is that if you consider the prior buy
then the prior pie
of b r n must be
not too small where b r n is a
neighborhood
of the optimal parameter that i will
denote by theta star
so in some sense it will be the set of
the parameter theta that have an excess
risk that is not too large with respect
to tita star
and if this set has a prior mass under
the prior
that is not too small then actually you
end up with
proof that bayesian inference
is convergent okay so
actually another way to understand this
assumption
is that if you consider the quantity
that is minimized
here when you're doing variational
approximation
and you consider this quantity not for
the minimizer p
but for p being the prior restricted on
the set
b that is on the neighborhood of theta
star and then actually you obtain that
this
is bounded okay so
this assumption that is quite classical
to study bayesian inference
has a kind of interpretation in terms of
violational inference
and then actually what's um
what i was interested in was to try to
understand if such a variational
approximation
so that is instead of considering the
the
the true minimizer um the posterior
i just consider the variational
approximation is it possible
to derive the same kind of consistency
results and
very recently there was a series of
papers i wrote
some of them with my quotas at nce
but like many papers appear recently
showing that
actually you can for the variational
approximation prove exactly the same
concentration results
that you can prove for the true
posterior but
under just a slight modification of this
condition that we call the prior mass
condition
so as i said the condition can be
interpreted
as the fact that the expected sum of the
losses plus the pullback
is not too far from the optimal
and this being for p being
the prior restrict restricted to a
neighborhood
of the optimal parameter and actually
what's
the main message of all the papers
listed in these slides
is that actually variational inference
will work
on the condition that in the variational
approximation timing for example in the
set of gaussian distributions
there is a distribution p that will
satisfy the same inequality
okay so all this um happened in the past
few
years month and the question that i want
to solve in this talk
is in this talk sorry is is it possible
to
do the same thing for kind of online
bayesian inference
okay so i will try to just be more
accurate and ask the questions
um precisely in the next two slides
so first you know that if you consider
the
uh the posterior you can see it as an
online update actually
which means that the posterior at time t
plus one
of course is given by exponential of
minus the sum of the loss function
between one and t
times the prior but you can also see it
as
the posterior at time t just multiplied
by the new loss that
uh arrives okay so this is why actually
in machine learning this is
often uh referred to as a multiplicative
rule
update instead of generalization
inference
the point is that if you decide if if
you know that
in your context pi t is too difficult to
be
computed or to be sampled from and if
you decide to use instead a variational
approximation
then how can you make sure
that this will still work if you
approximate by t
then you re-multiply by x minus minus
the loss function so you will have to
remake an approximation of the new thing
are you sure that the losses will not
cumulate and the errors will not
cumulate
um so how actually do you define such a
variational approximation in this
context was our first question
and the second question is um
if you use not the approximation but the
true posterior
then actually you have some regret bones
and the results that i write here
is very classical it is known find it in
every
textbook even though most of the time it
is cited actually
it is stated in the finite case that is
in the case where the set of parameters
is finite but
like it's the same idea here so the sum
of the expected losses will be bounded
by the infimum
of the sum of the expected losses plus a
reminder 10
that um that is given here and that
contains the coolback divergence between
the aggregation distribution queue and
the prior pi
okay so this is known for
the true posterior and once again like
um is it possible to derive a similar
result
for a variational approximation so for
something that would be computationally
feasible
just a remark actually it's something
that is not often re
written in this way i think but it's
maybe because um
it's two different communities so this
result this
regret bond is very well known in the
world of uh
online learning i think sorry but
then actually it's not very explicit so
you know that of course you will choose
eta and square root of
one over square root of t to try to get
a square root regret
but still you also have to compute the
kl between q and pi
and a way actually to do this in full
generality
uh is just to to invoke the prior mass
condition that is usually used in
asymptotic bayesian statistics so
interestingly enough
as the upper bound contains the the same
term that is the sum of the expectation
of the losses plus the callback
the prior mass condition just say that
this term is bounded in some sense
and so um for example under a prior mass
condition
with a radius in square root of log t
over t you will end up with a classical
regret bound like that and it appears
that
um in many cases like when you use
gaussian distribution for
priors and posteriors for example then
you will end up with
the prior mass condition being satisfied
for for this rate
actually so um it means that the
assumptions that i'll make that are made
usually in
asymptotic bayesian statistics if you
plug them i mean they are satisfied in
many
set of probability distributions and if
you plug them in this
uh regret bond then you obtain
like the usual order of magnitudes for
the for the regret
okay so as i said two questions can we
define sequential updates for
variational approximation and can we get
such a regret bound
well it appears that the the results
that i mentioned before
the four papers here uh studying this in
a
non-online setting in the batch setting
were quite technical
but in the online case it was all a
question of
framing everything into the right
framework so just
a reminder even though like uh sorry i
should have removed this slide because
of course to to
to to be a reminder of on your online
gradient algorithm and
unfollow the regularized leader is a
kind of joke in front of you like you
all know this
much better than i do but still well
given
um a set of predictors um
then actually you know that using the
online gradient algorithm
you would predict yt by ft of xt and
update theta t
by using the gradient of the loss that
you just received
immediately by your prediction
the point is that of course uh i i
remind this oh sorry just for short
actually i will replace from now
l of f theta t x t and y t by l
uh t of t t so i will just remove the x
t and y t
as is done usually to save space
the point is that i'm interested here
in the interpretation of this algorithm
in term of
follow the regularized leader okay so
you linearly linearize
the loss function and you can rewrite
this as the sum of the
linearized losses plus a penalty that is
theta minus theta
one the starting point over two eta or
alternatively actually
you can also rewrite it as just the
linearized
previous loss plus a penalty that says
that you don't go too far from just the
previous theta t
it's of course like you just know that
by differentiating either one or two
you end up immediately with the online
gradient update
and the idea is just like here to use
the generalized form of this that is uh
follow the regularized leader
but plugging as a penalization and as
the loss
what we want to control in online
directional inference
um that is actually um
we have our set of distributions say for
example gaussian
so okay it's too complicated to compute
my posterior distribution
so i will approximate it by your
question
so i decided this set of questions and
actually i will mimic
the distributor the definition of the
online gradient algorithm but by
changing the penalty
and in order to mimic what is done in
the inversion in
international inference i will either
define
mu t plus one as the minimizer of the
linearized
expectation of the losses plus the
pullback between q mu
and the prior or i could
if i mimic the second expression for the
online gradient
i could minimize the gradient of the
expected
losses i just received at time t plus
the callback divergence between q mu and
commuting
actually just a remark bad luck in
online gradient algorithm
one and two are equivalent in the um
in the bayesian or pseudo-based
framework they are no longer equivalent
so
the first proposition mu t plus one and
the second one
will not give exactly the same algorithm
still both seem natural actually so we
wanted to
to study both and um once again i think
that's
the the difficulty here was
mostly to cast the algorithm that were
already quite popular in practice into
the right framework to study them
because once you have this formula you
know that actually your t plus one
is an application of follow the
regularized leader
that will lead to a regret bond if you
have the
the correct assumptions and i will state
results later
but first just an example
when you use a gaussian approximation um
we need the computation and indeed it's
possible it's possible to find
uh like a kind of gradient type
update for the two versions so by the
way i forgot to say that the first
version i decided we decided to call
that
sva for sequential directional
approximation and the second one
svb for streaming variational bass so
sva we have actually just a gradient
update for m
and uh we have an update that is
slightly more complicated for the
variance sigma
so there is a function h that is given
just below and that we apply coordinate
wise
for svd uh it's
actually quite interesting the behavior
of the algorithm because in this case
um we update the mean and the variance
but what is interesting is that the
update of the mean
is actually a gradient step
but the step is given is proportional to
the variance
so in some sense even though our result
will not show this
we can expect some kind of adaptation
from from this algorithm
anyway so um as i said
the the question next was to try to uh
to provide a regret bond for this
algorithm
and uh well if you if you make the
adequate assumptions then actually this
is just follow the regularized leader
with a convex loss
and a strongly convex penalty so you
have a regret bond
so actually if you assume this so if you
assume that the loss is convex
and ellipse and if you assume that the
cutback
is alphas from e-complex then you have
the usual
regrets bound for this procedure
and what is interesting is that it
really looks like
what you would have for the exact base
procedure
so the classical regret bond that was
provided
before that is not this one proven as a
special instance of
follow the regularized leader but rather
proven with a opening inequality
and the um don't square the header
variational formula
so you obtain something that has the
same form and
as a consequence actually it means that
if you do once again the kind of
prior mass condition then you will
end up with
with a regret bond that has the usual
order of of magnitude
okay the point is that maybe it's a bit
um just of course easy to say
let's assume that everything is as it
should that's
that is that the loss is convex the
expected loss is convex
that is uh that the expected loss is
sleep sheets and that the cool back is
strongly convex uh the point is that we
we must check back in practice and the
good news is that there are results
saying that it's it holds in general
so if the loss is
leap sheets and convex then actually the
expected loss
in the case of any location scale model
will be lip sheets and convex as well
sorry excuse me i'm losing my voice
sorry so um
for the leap sheets um claim
actually it's almost trivial it just
take two or three lines to write it
for the complexity claim uh if you
choose the goshen family it's okay but
if you want to choose a more general
location scale family
for the approximation like maybe student
or anything else
then it becomes quite complicated and
there is a very nice paper by justin
donker actually um
that was published just in the past few
months where actually he proves um
these results like almost any location
scale family you will have like
the expectation will preserve lip sheets
and complexity so it's it's quite nice
um regarding the cool batch it appears
that um
when you deal with the most classical
example that is a gaussian
then um in this case
on the condition that you upper bound
the variance um
so that is that you constrain the
variance not to go
above a given threshold then you will
have uh the strong complexity assumption
so actually you have
this regret bond it will hold in
quite a natural setting
okay in a second time we performed
the analysis for svb so
i remind you maybe the difference just
once again so sva is when we use
um the qbank divergence with respect to
the prior and in svb we use the crew by
divergence with respect to
the posterior at the previous time step
and um in this case uh it's
it was just a bit more complicated in
the sense
that we are not able to provide a
general analysis if you use gaussian
approximations
then more or less it becomes quite
similar to what is done when you don't
have
actually any asian interpretation just
when you do a
gradient descent you just have to take
care of a few extra terms
and in this case we were able to recover
the
the usual rate that is uh in the convex
and if it's case
the square root of t regret and in the
strongly
convex case log t regret
really sorry i don't know what's
happening to my voice it's quite
difficult to talk
but this holds only for gaussian
approximations so we don't have
we don't have a general analysis for the
second algorithm only for the first one
i'll just take one more minute to talk
to you about the results
of the numerical experiments that we
performed we compared many algorithms
including our
sva and svb oga
is the ordinary online gradient
algorithm so you know it it's in yellow
here so you see that here sva is in blue
and svb is in purple um og-a-e-l i will
not talk to about that for now but
there is this ngvi mysterious for now
but i will
give a word on it uh later
that you can see here that this
mysterious ngvi
is better than everything else actually
gradient here is the worst one and then
sva slightly better svb
really better and ngvi is the best
and we hoped that we would identify a
pattern
uh it's not the case actually so here is
another
example of classification on another
data set
and here you can see that actually the
bayesian methods oops sorry
the bayesian methods sva and svb are
blue and purple they are convergent but
they are not the best these times and
the online gradient algorithm is better
still this green thing here is much
better
and on in all the simulations we did
like this is
the we did like many many data sets and
always always what happened was that all
the methods work
but there is no clear hierarchy between
them apart from this ngdi
in in green actually is almost always
the best method
ngdi by the way i should say is
the algorithm that was at the basis of
the idea used in this paper
in the uh in the uh deep learning
beijing deep learning paper
so it was the one that we wanted to
study initially
the point is that um when i come back
to my final slide actually there is a
short explanation here on ngvi
and it is based actually on the same id
that's kind of follow the regularized
leader where the penalty
is a cue back but the point is that it
does not use the same parameterization
that we used okay so
here i i talked briefly like about this
mean and sca
and scale parameterization it does not
choose the mean and scale
parametrization it uses natural
parameterization in the exponential
family
which is very nice because it makes many
calculations quite simple
but on the other hand it destroys the
convexity of the loss and of the
coolback
so for this reason this algorithm that
works very well in practice
is not in the framework of our
theoretical results and that's one of
the open questions actually
important to me is to be able to extend
the analysis
to this algorithm
still we were quite happy to have these
results because up to our knowledge it
was the first time that there were some
theoretical results
on the validity of uh online variational
inference
and uh there are a few other questions
including like the second one i think
it's quite important because in this
case like as i said
base is usually motivated by uncertainty
quantification but still the regret
bounds
basically just give result on prediction
and not on uncertainty quantification
so it would also be nice to check if
actually these methods provide a
reliable
uncertainty quantification this is not
stated by the results yet so there is
still some work to be to be done
thank you for your attention and sorry
for losing my voice
i hope that you could understand me
still
thanks very greg gergie has
uh yeah yeah thank you this is this is
very interesting work
and i guess it's not easy to speak at
1am
so so my question is so like do you
assume that your variational class is
convex here or can you explain where
exactly the complexity is happening
in these optimization problems so
actually um you're
you're right it's something quite
important actually because
if you want to it's possible for example
it's possible to derive through this
regret
here by working
on i'm sorry there is some kind of echo
so i cannot hear myself i don't know if
uh
okay um yes here
[Music]
the the the result given here can be
proven actually as a kind of
follow the regularized leader but then
in this case you have to work
on the set of all probability
distributions
which can be quite large
in what we do here actually the idea in
some sense
was just to avoid working in the set of
probability distributions
and just to work with parameters so for
example
you take gaussian family and the
optimization
is no longer on the set of probability
distribution it's just on the set of
mean and on the set of variances
so the vector m and the covariance
matrix sigma
so actually in this case the parametric
sets that you try to optimize in is
convex if you try to keep the first
approach
and if you want to come back to this
proof you will have problems because
in the set of probability distributions
the set of gaussian distribution is not
a convex subset
so actually the idea was just to
transfer all the work
on the space of parameters rather than
on the space of probability
distributions i hope this answers your
your question yes yes it definitely does
and i and i want
and i guess this was really the
challenge that you had to face when
trying to analyze svb
right because there you have the
sequential projections back to the space
and that really needs complexity for
like mirror descent algorithms
yeah okay at least that's my guess
given this answer but but it's very
helpful
so do you need convexity of the set to
prove convexity of the loss function i
don't see why like in f
aren't you using the fact that it's an
infimum over certain set
to prove convexity of the last function
i missed the beginning of the question
i'm sorry i did not hear the beginning
so do you need convexity of the set of
distributions to prove convexity of the
loss function
or is it just for like efficiency of no
no
of the fine so
if you come back to our results actually
you just have a loss function l
um you compute the expectation of l with
respect to a probability distribution
that is parameterized by mu say for
example a gaussian with mean mu
and you just need this to be convex with
respect to the parameter
mu
and sorry the strong complexity
assumption is on
what then the loss function with respect
to theta
or or this expected loss under q
i mean in this result here that is
stated here you have convexity on
l and strong convexity on the cool back
between q mu and pi
right but i thought that's always
strongly convex at least in terms of one
norm
i figured that the kl divergence is
always strongly convex with respect to
the one
oh what all you mean like with respect
to mu exactly exactly
oh i see that's very tricky i mean
of course like if you work in the world
of probability distributions
right then yes it is it is always but it
is always but you you are no longer
working on the convex set
because uh if you have two gaussian
distributions
then just there the the the linear
combination of the two questions is not
no longer a question right
so here the point is it's frustrating in
some sense we cannot work with
the natural object we have to work with
a parameter and when you
work with the parameter suddenly you can
have strange things that happen and you
can have
a callback that is no longer a convex
function sometimes of the parameter
it's the case for example with the
parametrization that is taken
sorry what i mentioned in the last slide
actually empty can
he has this non-convex parametrization
which surprisingly works very well but
we're not able to prove
why
all right thank you that's very
illuminating thanks very much for
clarifying
so one more question i had was since you
are going to not be part of the
discussion
i'm extending this a little bit sorry uh
david to delay or talk a little bit
um i just wanted to like have your
opinion on since you're not you're using
this generalized bayesian
inference and not using log likelihood
in the like which
which would come out if you did the
regular variational inference
uh is scale divergence still a natural
distance measure to use then like
okay it kind of comes out naturally if
you in variational inference with log
likelihood but maybe here
since the loss function is not really
like likelihood
so you you mean that you would say for
example
um here
why do i use as a penalty the pullback
labeler rather than something else
right actually i think this is a very
good question thank you for giving me
the opportunity to advertise for a
preprint that i just
posted on the archive a few weeks ago
so i was interested in this question
like
should i take the kl or should i take
something else
it appears that if you replace kl by
something else
you obtain
something that is sometimes interesting
because you can uh
slightly change the the hypothesis on
your algorithm
so for example even when you don't have
any variational approximation
when you work with the full
any probability distribution
distribution q setting actually
if you replace the kl by another
divergence
you can get rid of the assumption that
the loss is bonded here
l but the price to pay
is that usually for all the other
divergences i tried
you have a worse regret bond which means
that actually you don't have square root
of
t but you can have something that is
bigger
so apart from like
removing some hypothesis that can be
useful of course but
apart from that i am not convinced yet
actually so i've seen
actually i didn't know that but since i
posted this new preprint
i i realized that many people actually
tried this idea to replace
the kl by something else and there are
very elegant results
but the
application in practice maybe it will be
very helpful maybe not but
i'm i don't know yet actually so
that's thank you yeah we thank you for
uh unless there are any pressing
questions i think we should move on to
the next talk
uh david can you